deux ans et demi que le projet a été
lancé au sein de cette association
destinée à transmettre la flamme de la
bd aux plus jeunes
ici on des signes de 7 à 77 ans dans des
styles très différents on échange
beaucoup sur les techniques alors la
parution du premier volume de 180 pages
et pour tous un événement qui est la
consécration avec avec l'objet ça c'est
vraiment chouette je passe encore plus
pour eux pour eux que pour nous parce
que c'est une première fois pour voir
que nous on a déjà été défloré sur ce
sujet et mais c'est toujours plaisant en
fait de de découvrir l'objet tarifs à
nous ils s'intéressent aux mangas comme
beaucoup de jeunes il a produit pour ce
premier opus une histoire de 25 pages
et encore un peu de mal à réaliser c'est
quelque chose parce que ça va faire deux
ans et demi pour travailler dessus et là
on est arrivé à l'aboutissement de ce
travail
arrivé à la fin on a lu le bouquin en
sait quelque chose
simon a également participé en
produisant son histoire particularité le
jeune garçon qui vit à orléans fait le
trajet pour venir entendre grâce à ses
parents et grands parents et pour rien
au monde il n'aurait voulu manquer cela
ça fait plaisir de voir sa bd réalisée
et puis bah voila je suis contente a
fait un essai du travail pour créer
imaginer la bd tout mais sinon non pour
s'intégrer au groupe non pas forcément
donc tu vas continuer de venir autant
que tu peux pas tous des moyens ici donc
oui j'ai un manager édité grâce à un
financement participatif qui a bien
fonctionné
l'album sera vendu 10 euros tous
espèrent que cette première pourra
continuer car l' aventure confirme le
président a été très bénéfique aux
jeunes pour voir d'autres aspects du
métier comme la fabrication le
maquettage ou encore la
commercialisation